good morning John this is part of a
series I'm calling vlog extra days in
April which I hope you will join me in
weird weird
what is there's a little guy here
I think I accidentally just found a
geocache that's exactly what it is and
that's gross
it looks like there's some gross stuff
in there I'm going down to the river now
it's more of a creek or as they say in
Montana Creek I don't know why it's
pretty
basically this coming down here to find
a nice place to film so hopefully I will
find one of those ooh that's pretty good
make sure my butt crack isn't showing
floated to do something that no one had
ever done before an adaptation in online
video taking a previous work and
transferring it into this new media
there's not I don't know of any examples
of this happening I wanted something
that was a great story that I loved and
I wanted to make this kind of something
that that my wife would really enjoy and
I wanted to think that was very dialog
based and very character-based so that
we could do it not as a big production
with lots of sets and scenes and
everything but just as a person talking
to a camera it's a work of fiction
adapted into a video blog and a work of
fiction that we chose this Pride and
Prejudice because you know it's the best
story of all time such a wonderful
romance and the characters of all so
much and I'm so interested in the end of
story and I never would have been if it
hadn't been for Katherine of course but
she is a huge P&P fan basically a
scholar it's much much different than
anything I've ever done like I prefer to
be alone right this is like resting on a
tree right now whereas this yeah sound
guy in production people and writers in
organizing all these people and that's
something that is totally new to me and
also like making a story because because
I feel like vlogbrothers is a story but
it wasn't intentionally a story we
didn't set out to like start here and
end up here and have a middle to
wonderful story it's my favorite story
ever but with this we're actually
telling a story we have to figure out
how to break it up and how to write it
and how to transfer it into the present
day because obviously it's not a period
piece it's really new and really
exciting for me to do something that
that's so different and of course like I
don't have time for this but here I am
doing it anyway because iowa's is so
captured by the idea and it's also
important to note that it's very
different from what I'm doing and thus
it I don't really know how to get it out
there there's part of me that's like I
know this is good so what do I have to
do now to actually get people to watch
it we've made eight episodes and to make
more than eight episodes we're going to
have to you know somehow prove that
people want to watch it so either we can
get a sponsor or we can just get enough
views that we can pay for
it's pretty you know honestly dangerous
because it's very different from the way
that any other fiction story has been
told before so it's entirely possible
that it just will not be a good way to
tell a story and I hope that that's not
the case I don't feel like that's the
case but it's possible and that people
won't react well to it you don't like it
that's fine and I am not worried it's
it's I consider it to be an extremely
exciting experiment so that's that's out
feeling and I hope that I hope that you
like straight up I hope that you like it
I hope that you enjoy it and if you do
please share it and hopefully we can
make this a sustainable project and
we'll get to tell the whole story
lizzie bennet call and Charlotte Lu
Charlotte Lu she's called Charlotte Lu
in the show Charlotte Lucas in the book
now I have to go to dinner party oh it's
friends of mine and now I'm home dinner
party look at my friend Dan got me in
the Monon I'm gonna put an annotation up
so you could check out Lizzie Bennet
diaries John you will see me tomorrow
because I'm vlogging extra days in April
dftba